last talk for today
talk is given by Cuba juansky and it's
on Dynamic page rank
um yeah so this is Joint work with Raj
aslaboran
so so far in this Workshop we've seen a
lot of great talks with some deep
algorithmic ideas
in some sense this talk is going to be
an exact opposite uh like what are we
talking about is going to be quite
simple but I would like to use it as an
opportunity to discuss some challenges
in applying Dynamic algorithm practice
as well as also maybe discussing a
problem which at least in the dynamic
version I guess you don't often see
studied in in theory conferences
all right so uh let's Jump Right In let
me start by defining pagerank
so the input here is a directed graph we
assume that the out degree of each
vertex is non-zero you can deal with the
with the other case as well but let's
ignore this for the for Simplicity here
and we have a single parameter Alpha
which is the jumping probability
and now to Define pagerank we Define a
Markov chain on the set of vertices of V
with probability Alpha Over N we jump to
a random vertex from and then other
otherwise with the remaining probability
we follow a uniformly random out edge of
the vertex we're in
so if we write this in The Matrix form
in this Matrix each entry has value
Alpha divided by n Plus for the entries
which correspond to the edges there is
an additional term corresponding to
following the edges and the patron
problem is simply to compute a
stationary distribution of the Markov
chain described this way now for my talk
this definition is going to be
completely irrelevant I'm going to use
one which is easier to use
algorithmically
which is the following one to compute
page rank we do as follows we start we
pick a Vertex V uniformly at random and
then we follow a page rank walk from V
and now pagerank block I wrote it in
bold because it's a term I'm going to
use a lot throughout this talk
you can define a pagerank walk I first
pick K from geometric distribution of
parameter Alpha and then I run a
uniformly random walk from V of length K
so basically I start in K with
probability Alpha I sub immediately with
the remaining probability I I take a
random out Edge at that point I stop
with probability Alpha and if I don't
stop I follow a uniformly random outage
and so on
so this is this is what I get from this
geometric distribution
and now pagerank is also a probability
distribution Pi such that P of V is the
probability that the that the work
defined this way stops in v
any questions
to be consistent with the
is it Alpha here or that is it is that
consistent with the previous definition
yes I think it's consistent here uh here
I wanted uh Alphas I wanted each row and
a row or column yeah I mean I wanted
each each
here
okay does this make sense
so no according to this definition the
Longs are fairly fairly long right
because you only jump with probability
yes okay so I think there's a typo here
with probably Alpha jumper and the
vertex sorry okay right thanks yeah
everything else was good thanks uh
yeah so that makes sense right now not
right okay
uh good more questions
okay so I guess we can continue and now
Dynamic page rank is exactly what you
may expect we have a graph and it's
undergoing changes we can add edges we
can delete edges and we'd like to
explicitly maintain an approximate page
rank vector by
now for this talk I'm gonna assume it's
explicit maintenance it's actually the
same as saying that every update outputs
a list of changes to the pagerank vector
and this is a very convenient uh
interface because for example if I would
like to I can maintain using this output
I can maintain the top one percent of
vertices with the largest patrons or
some other statistics on paychecks if I
were just given a query interface it
would be extremely difficult to tell
what has changed after a particular uh
insertion or uh deletion
and I will be assuming that all the
algorithms must have this kind of
problem
and then again
you think following standard terminology
we say an algorithm is fully Dynamic if
it supports both additions and lesions
incremental if we can only add edges and
decremental if edges can only be I
believe it's nothing very surprising
here yes
why is this
why is this formulated only with
additions and deletions of edges why
don't you delete and add vertices
um
I think it's it's
in a sense something that does not
change well okay for page rank it's a
good question
usually you know you can have like a
pool of vertices right on the side that
um that you can
um you can just
as preemptively to the graph just just
in case you need them in the future and
you know having adding a Vertex is
equivalent you know just grabbing
grabbing an unused vertex so far and
connecting it to your graph I think it's
it's actually the same here if you if
you play with the probabilities uh so
it's it I think you can do that but it's
just like a technical annoyance it's not
uh it's not something that changes the
problem in a fundamental way so this is
where the core of the problem lies
all right so now time for for our
results the first one is the lower bound
showing that uh for any any number n any
graph size any incremental algorithm
which processes a linear number of
insertions to an N vertex graph and
maintains a constant Factor approximate
page rank must run in essentially
quadratic time this basically means that
if we want to explicitly maintain page
rank it's it's hopeless we need
quadratic time at the same time you can
compute pagerank from scratch in
essentially end poly login time so this
almost matches almost matches the upper
bound and it actually resolves an open
question that was erased some 13 years
back this question was partially
addressed before uh there were some
impossibility results for this
particular algorithm and we showed that
it actually holds for any algorithm that
maintains pagerank explicitly
as you may guess the proof just shows
and it's the graph in an insertion
sequence where the number of changes to
the pagerank vector is is almost
quadratic and the same thing holds for
decremental algorithms not very
surprising because you can play the
whole update sequence backwards
there's a two approximate you mean uh
every component is yes it's a component
wise to approximation there could be
other kinds yes that's coming up next
slide okay
yes so so now
since we know that maintaining constant
Factor approximate uh solution is is
hard we turn our attention to other
Notions of approximation so
multiplicative C approximation is what I
now Define having it used on the
previous slide so it's just a component
wise see approximation of the patron
vector and then an additive C
approximation is just saying that the L1
error or L1 difference between the exact
page Rank and my solution is at most uh
C
so we know that multiplicative FC
approximation is hard
we all know what's coming up now we show
that maintain maintaining additive
approximation is actually doable for any
constant Epsilon we can show both
incremental and decremental algorithms
which maintain Epsilon additive
approximation to pagerank and run in
near the near total time
now the caveats is that the exponent in
the polylog depends both on Alpha that's
not too bad because like Alpha is is
typically set close to one half but also
on Epsilon and that's actually worse
because we may want uh we may want
Epsilon to be pretty small yeah I mean
okay the scale of Epsilon right
don't I want the probability of a given
page to be very very small
sorry could you repeat
if I have n Pages overall the number
you're trying to
if all pages were equally valid
then we'd want something like 1 over n
well this is this is additive right so
right so yes I mean if you if you want
to have some kind of multiplicative
guarantee yes like a large Epsilon can
means that we may be very much wrong for
those for those small values
unless we make it extremely small yes
um
it turns out that actually patreon of
any vertex is at least Alpha divided by
n there is a lower bound and then on the
other hand in in applications we're
mostly interested in vertices of large
page rank so which which to some extent
motivates uh studying also this notion
but yeah it is weaker especially for the
vertices with with small Patron balance
I all right I guess
so this race
this raises the question then can you
can you have some kind of mix where for
the pages of very small page rank they
still stay very very small but with the
ones that are larger uh you can tolerate
in epsilon error
[Music]
yeah the lower bottom we show I think
it's it actually uh
yeah I think it it does not rule out I
think those cases I think it's like we
show like that many vertices would
oscillate between constant and like one
over polylog page rung so it I think
yeah this is actually a good question
it's not allowed us but at least by our
lower Bond foreign
and now a third result uh third result
relies on a battery computation approach
a battery computation approach is what I
what I Define here so it's an algorithm
which first computes an initial page
rank vector and then does nothing for
some number of of updates it just reuses
this initial Vector for some time and
only after sufficiently many updates
accumulate it recomputes pagerank from
scratch so it's a very crude approach uh
to to solving page rank it's almost like
like solving uh well that's almost like
solving the problem from scratch except
that we do nothing for many steps uh so
sounds like a sounds like a very bad
idea except that it's it's actually not
to our surprise uh so we can both show
good theory and empirical results
um for this particular algorithm so we
can show for for a battery computation
algorithm that I'm going to specify in
detail later we can show that it can
handle any sequence of random updates in
uh almost linear time in both
incremental and decremental settings as
well as if none of the page rank is too
large we can we can also maintain page
rank in a fully Dynamic setting in time
um roughly o of B in each step if if
each payer if each page rank is at most
beta or over added this algorithm is
extremely efficient in practice which to
some extent is like a sad information to
to like people working on on Dynamic
algorithms because we see that now that
we take a very a very simple approach
and it it then turns out to outperform
uh perhaps more clever and more clever
approaches that we're considered before
later
um so this is for you're doing this on
very large large graphs and so isn't
there what about like is there a problem
with um
you know I I guess what what model are
you I mean there's like a cash issue
with all these I mean the random one I
don't know how I was curious will you
get to how you're implementing this
stuff yes I mean this one yeah I will
talk about how we do that later yeah and
also like I try to explain what what's
happening that that this is why this is
performing actually pretty well yeah
thanks uh
okay I could imagine that computes an
initial pagerank Vector on
um real data sets uh maybe taking the
last page rank Vector that you computed
would be a good starting point and I'm
just wondering as an order of magnitude
how much faster does that converge than
if you took say a random page rank
vector
sorry I don't know
when you say compute's an initial page
rank Vector yeah so this means that we
just compute um an almost exact page
rank using power method in in practice
right okay any method well I just is
there any consideration at all of not
starting with a good seat like I'm
presuming starting with a good C is like
super crucial in making this conversion
yeah but it's also it's also cheap so
okay I mean it's cheap enough that we
can do it so why not do it why not use a
good solution
it always converges with one over Alpha
hydration whenever you start from it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter okay so
I don't know what the theory is oh I see
so you're saying for the iterative
process of starting the oh yeah
um I think we actually started uniform
and then had a bunch of power iterations
I don't we we didn't actually so the
empirical results hold even without
really optimizing the the recombination
algorithm uh but we use a very simple
implementation we did not even tune that
and even so it was working well but yeah
we'll get to that later
so just to understand this so you're not
doing personal page rank no it's only
for page ranking okay right because uh
personal present could be much larger
than order one hour and yes personal
page rank it does not have does not have
some of nice properties yeah this is per
patreon which is a slightly simple
problem
okay thank you
uh okay let's let's move on so we're
done with the green section uh so now
let's move to the blue one so review
some some prior work and then we'll
discuss our result in more detail and
I'll I'll uh we'll then wrap up and show
some more problems
okay so now this slide is going is also
very important we're gonna use this
algorithm a lot to explain what's going
on later so please please make sure you
you you you you you see what's what's
happening and ask me questions if
something is not clear
so uh we would like to compute pagerank
via random work sampling this is an
algorithmic version of the the
definition that I provided
so we have three parameters in addition
to Alpha which defines the problem we
want to solve we have two all two
parameters of the algorithm so we have
Epsilon and an individual l
and so what we'll do is we'll set
compute R which is roughly log n
and that will sample our pagerank works
starting from each vertex of of G and
then we remove all works longer than L
hops this step is not really important
if we just want to solve a static
problem but it will become important
once we once we make make this algorithm
dynamic
and then we do a simple thing for each
vertex V we just compute the number of
logs that stop at this vertex and then
we turn this into a probability
distribution so we just normalize so
just to get a property distribution Pi
you can show that this computes a
multiplicative one plus absolute
approximation or page rank with
hyperability
the algorithm clear
foreign
so just a note this algorithm computes 9
log n divided by Alpha squared times
Epsilon random walks per vertex so from
Theory point of view this is great this
is just log n which we typically
consider a small number but in practice
if you start plugging in actual values
you can see that this easily goes in in
thousands and to justify the picture
this is actually the same the very same
picture just just rotated just to
illustrate how looking at the same thing
from different perspectives may lead to
different
different observations
um okay so now how do we make this
algorithm Dynamic this was the this was
done in a paper in vldb2010 by bakmani
Chaudhary and goel I'm going to refer to
this algorithm as BCG for short
and the algorithm is just a direct
dynamization of the previous algorithm
we will maintain a collection of page
rank walks and we will update that
whenever needed
so for example when we delete an edge we
just well what does it break it breaks
only the random works that use that that
particular Edge and we have to resample
them and so there are some important
important caveats for each resampled
walk we must make sure that the length
of this work becomes uh stays the same
otherwise this would introduce a bias so
we do not resample the walk length from
geometry distribution we keep it what it
was
and we only resample the part of the
walk after X again if we resample the
entire walk which is what some papers
have suggested this does introduce
biases and actually there we also tested
that it is clearly visible in practice
even more than what we thought would be
the case
you have to maintain all the walks that
go through an edge yes we yeah so
actually yes for each Edge we will have
to to maintain exactly every single walk
that goes in to it so that when the
ledge is deleted we can access those
walks efficiently
and then when I just add it we also do a
similar an easy thing for every walk if
we add an edge from X to Y for every
walk going through X we reroute it to
use this new edge with probability one
divided by the new degree of X and again
there are some caveats the length of the
walks need to stay the same and also
there's a tricky case when I walk visits
X multiple times you need to play with
the probabilities but but yeah it's not
too difficult to get it right
so and then this way we just at every
step we maintain uh we maintain a
uniform and independent distribution of
random walks of course I'm assuming
oblivious adversary here uh adaptive
other service yeah we will briefly
mention towards the end
uh and so this all this essentially
inherits the algorithm the the
guarantees of the static algorithm in
terms
so here's a theorem it maintains one
plus Epsilon approximation of pagerank
and if all of the edge deletions are
uniformly random and the total update
time is and R is roughly n times r r is
just a log so this is n poly log n it's
not even yeah it can be even sublinear
if the number of edges is large enough
oh
and
this is this is a time for this is a
total time of handling all updates for
any sequence of random Edge deletions
yeah like if you start with any graph
delete all the edges in random order
this is this is the total update time
you get yeah
so a proof idea it actually fits in the
remaining part of the slide
there are n times R random walks each of
expected length one over Alpha
and so when I delete a random Edge I
will likely not hit a lot of them
I mean this is perfectly uniformly
uniformly random I will hit this many
walks in expectation which is a small
number right if m is large this can be
this can be a sub constant
and and only this small number of logs
needs to be rerouted rerouting a single
box takes time
proportional to its length so it's also
fast and this way we get we get the
bound
all right there is also a second
algorithm but I'm in the interest of
time let me skip that I will not be
using that later it also has a dynamic
version
but yeah let's move on to our results
so the first one is the lower bound
which I did mention uh I think I will
also uh I will skip the construction it
may also may be a bit less relevant
let's go to algorithms
so I I showed you before this was result
number two that if we uh that if we
um
assume that we if we are interested in
bounding L1 error we can do that in
polylog amortize update time
here is the the corresponding algorithm
it's adapted again from the static
algorithm that I showed before we sample
that many uh that many page rank walks
per vertex each length is chosen from
this distribution but now we we TR we
remove all walks longer than this much
this is a constant depending on Alpha
and Epsilon and then everything else
follows us as before so I'm running the
static algorithm except that I'm
throwing away all the works that are
longer than constant
so natural question is how badly do I
mess up the the approximation in
particular this is not even a
probability distribution like because
um
because out of that many that many
sampled works I uh I I take I only take
count those that were actually run this
does not add up to one sorry this should
say this should say the number of works
that ended these are this formulation is
also that can also be made to work but
yeah but the one I'm using for this talk
is we count the number of walks that
that can't add vertex V
and so the question is how much error do
I introduce by throwing away all the
longer walks well it's easy to compute
the probability that the walk deleted in
step three is is more than L is at most
that much from geometry distribution and
that's just absolute over two
so from all the walks that I run uh I'm
going to delete an Epsilon over to
fraction of them so my L1 error is only
going to increase by by absolute number
two Factor so I'm not actually I'm not
um introducing a lot of error by
limiting the walk length and as we will
see on the next slide having walks of
constant length makes their maintenance
easier
uh
why is that Well turns out that if we
have walks of constant length
maintaining them under say deletions or
or insertions I think I'm using
insertions on this slide it's all
symmetric
implies a low running time
so let's let's take a look at a specific
vertex V and let's assume that add
outgoing edges are being added to this
vertex so when the ith outcoming Edge is
added to this vertex the walk is
re-routed with probability I
so from a harmonic sum argument the
number of rewritings of this of this
walk for this particular vertex is going
to be at most logarithmic right so I
have a Vertex this this only outgoing
guide was chosen I add some edges but
only say when the third edges is being
um yeah when the sorry when the second
Edge is being added I reroute it with
probability half on the third edges
being added I reroute the work
probability third and so on and it all
sums up to to log n
so for a single hop the probability of
sorry the number of reroutings is slogan
and then you can show that a walk of
length L is rerouted in expectation log
to l
n times which gives me the Bound for the
algorithm
so from Theory point of view this all
works now as you may imagine this
exponent is terribly bad and we will
actually see that uh that even though
this is technically polylog this
algorithm is not is not visibly faster
than say
um not even limiting the walk length
let's go
thank you so that was that was algorithm
two and now perhaps the simplest
algorithm which is the battery
computation here is
what I mean by batchware computation uh
in more detail
so the algorithm maintains just two
things My Graph and the single integer T
which just tells me how many more
operations until I recompute from
everything from scratch
to initialize the algorithm I call it
recompute so I compute approximate page
rank of G
in our experiments we were just using
power methods but you can also use
random work sampling if you want if
you're interested in in theory bounds
and then when after that I say that I
would like to recompute after I delete a
constant factor of all the edges
I'm going to use a parameter gamma to
control for that
and now when I add or delete an edge I
just I will do nothing well I will
update the graph just to record that the
update happened I will decrease T and
only do some non-trivial recomputation
once I reach the point where I want to
recompute from scratch
that's it so the philosophical question
if this is even a dynamic algorithm or
or a static one that we run uh
periodically but I mean it's uh well in
some sense we are able to show bounds
better than running the the page rank
after after
clear
um
so now let's try to analyze this
approach why does this uh how can we
bound the theoretical properties
um
so let's look again at the algorithm
that we started with the one that
maintains a collection of random walks
so now when we delete a random match we
were saying well this random Edge
deletion only hit a cost a small
fraction of random walks so now
previously I was saying I will uh I will
reroute them but I can also say I will
do nothing and my error will not
increase by a lot in expectation so it's
a very similar similar argument I'm
saying that a random deletion if I
totally ignore it with an expectation
not change my not change my uh pagerank
by a lot and the proof goes
by this random work sampling algorithm
right we we affect few of the random
works and so naturally we cannot change
the result of that page of that random
work based algorithm in a significant
way
I think it's it's
both simple and together if it's if it's
not pure I'm happy to elaborate
um but if you have questions could you
please stop me so if we do nothing the
L1 error under a random deletion
increases by by just one over M times
Alpha so by a very tiny amount and so we
don't need to do anything until a
constant fraction of edges are deleted
from the graph
yes John
I'm just wondering about the first one
is there is there some underlying
assumption that the degrees are not that
different uh so I'm so so here's why I'm
I I'm like here's a here's the point I'm
not sure what so if I have a graph where
the degrees are really off right like so
so let's just say you have a star and
one off one of the ends of the star
there's a single vertex
so
this this uh this cut Edge or I mean all
of them architis but this extra is that
a single vertex is hanging off of 1 by n
fraction oh let's say a click and a
single one one by n fraction of the
random Works will go through this Edge
but if you have a click every other Edge
will get very small 1 over N squared
fraction of the edges of the random
marks
yes but so deleting a random Edge but I
think the difference between these two
cases is that the number of edges varies
a lot right between these two no so okay
sorry I think I switched my examples so
let's have a Click N squared and then
you take an extra Edge and attach just
an isolated vertex for this extra Edge
you have
all the random works out of the out of
the new vertex coming right so that's
one by n fraction of the random box
that's much more than one over m
M um yes but in your example
um
I think
but that edge is very unlikely to be
picked right because I mean very
unlikely it's it's one out of N squared
edges right
okay
right but but it affects oh I see I see
I see okay thank you yes sir any more
questions
so the the bug that you initially
mentioned it's not on the random updates
right so this is just for
sure sorry the what the theorem that you
stated at the beginning no this there
are two packs this is under random
updates and then there is also another
one under other arbitrary updates
if we have random updates a single
update cannot change my page rank much
so if I do nothing my solution is uh is
still
it is still pretty good and I can show
that the number of battery computations
is just constant across my whole stream
and so I get like the running time of
employ logarithm this is on the random
updates and under uh adversarial updates
if I say that the page rank of the
vertex is at most beta Over N I can show
that at most beta poly login page rank
Works leave every vertex and so again
um
that many patreon Works can use any any
out edge of this vertex so again
deleting a single a single edge cannot
affect a lot of walks and so my patreon
will not change but will not change by
much and I get the same update time
times
okay so that was theoretical analysis
but now the interesting part and I see I
need to speed up is is our empirical
results
so we implemented uh those algorithms in
C plus plus we use temporal graph data
set from snap which means we had
directed graphs and the edges all had
like some time stamp attached to them
which we use to define the order of or
adding or deleting edges actually for
the experiment we just were just
deleting edges
and then we considered two orders of
edge deletions random and also the
temporal one which came with the data
set
and we looked at two algorithms there is
the BCG algorithm which maintains
pagerank works with two parameters the
number of walks we sample per vertex and
a cup of the on the length of the random
walk we saw that in theory at least
capping random work lengths helps and
then simple page rank is just the
battery computation approach what we
what we parameterize it with is just the
number of recomputations we
all right so for the first experiments
we were looking at what is the effect of
limiting walk lengths so we maintain uh
we maintain pagerank walks using the BCG
algorithm we delete edges in random
order
on the x-axis we have time on the y-axis
we have the error so we want to be in
the bottom left corner
and then we vary both both parameters
the number of walks and the maximum
length of the walk so each curve here is
what happens to the the the the error
time trade-off as we increase the as we
increase the the the allowed length of
of each random walk so basically this
means that that recap uh the recap the
length of each random walks at one and
the bonds here mean that we cap the
length of each random block at say 128.
and essentially the best error to time
trade of
is when we do not cap the walk length at
all
so this means that actually
out of these two parameters
tuning the number of walks gives us a
better trade-off between error and time
than limiting block length it's uh start
a realization that our theory for that
part did not lead us to to something
that we can see in any in any way
so that was like a negative result
and then we also see that we need more
than 2 000 walks in order to get one
error of like of one percent
and now uh second thing is that we saw
that the battery computation is very
efficient under L1 error now we were not
we were we compared the bcgn simple page
rank algorithms now since limiting walk
lengths did not prove to be useful we
just tuned the number of walks sampled
for the BCG algorithm and the number of
recomputations for the battery
computation approach we consider two
order of Edge deletions and we plot the
results so these are the different
trade-offs we get by tuning the number
of battery computations for for the
simple algorithm and this is the
different results we get if we tune the
number of work samples for BCG and we
see that we get almost a thousand XP up
by recomputing from scratch as opposed
to maintaining run random box
so now you may say that what I did in
the previous experiment is not fair
because I'm using L1 error and this was
like tailored to my algorithm
while at the same time BCG is also
giving me multiplicative error which is
a harder thing to do and it's actually a
fair point we also considered it
so we also looked at an error measure
inspired by applications so by so we
essentially we looked at how good these
algorithms are in identifying vertices
of very light very large page rank this
is an error measure which none of the
algorithms is designed for in the
interest of time let me skip the precise
definition and just show the result
well
bottom line is that we the the advantage
is smaller but we still see a good speed
up at the same quality of the simple
recomputation approach
um one other thing is that you may
Wonder because we recompute from scratch
periodically we may Wonder well maybe
the error is terrible every now and then
again
yes it can be bad but compared to the to
the BCG algorithm is is often much
slower and this is tuned such that the
simple pagerank algorithm is actually
faster in this case the green line in
case you're wondering is if we don't
remember about the caveats that that I
mentioned
okay so uh a natural question I think
Valerie was asking about that is why is
this so efficient
so these experimental results were this
for random deletions or whether it's
your snap uh graphs where you had
actually really worked we actually
consider both uh both random and
temporal they're not too far from each
other okay the axes are temporal circles
are random and actually what you can see
I'm glad you asked
actually the temporal order like the
random order is something I always think
of as being easy the temporal order
turns that turned out to be easier than
random which I also found quite
surprising
uh two minutes I'll need to rush a
little bit okay so why is this better
computation so so fast well I think
there are a few few reasons first of all
the the recomputation algorithm is very
efficient like we do we use power method
which is just like a sequential scan
over Edge array multiple times that's
great with respect to cash we could also
make it much faster using
parallelization we did not do that that
would probably widen the Gap by another
order of magnitude
at the same time we saw that pagerank in
reality changes slowly like the plots we
saw there I think that we can say that
the temporal deletions appear to be even
better than random deletions so we saw
that for random deletions patreon does
not change by a lot with temporal
deletions that's not any different so
that was not another reason why why this
why this worked well we could
essentially apply the or the results in
some sense carried over from the random
case
and on the other hand the BCG algorithm
has large very large constant Associated
we need to maintain a lot of random
walks and the algorithm is inherently
cash unfriendly because of the random
walks maintenance requires you to do a
lot of uh a lot of
um random memory accesses also in terms
of space usage I think there is like a
hundred if not thousand difference the
well the BCG algorithm uses uses orders
of magnitude more space
okay so let me let me sum up
so a couple of open questions one is
that the BCG algorithm can be shown to
handle fully Dynamic updates in poly
login time
if our graph is uh undirected so that's
a very strong assumption and if we
assume an oblivious adversary
now one question is what about adaptive
adversaries we have not considered that
we know that maintaining perfectly
random walks is essentially impossible
and we know using what the technique
that touchables show that we can
maintain a page rank of single vertex in
roughly written time but we can probably
get a decent approximation of page rank
using almost uniformly random works and
the question is can be can this be made
to work
second thought that I wanted to share is
is on using Dynamic algorithms in
practice
so when we develop theoretical
algorithms I think our objective is to
have a good good running time bound with
approximation bounds but we probably
also want the write-up to fit in maybe
50 or 100 pages of a PDF this is like
our this is this is our limit on the
complexity of the algorithm but in
practice it you know in practice there
is much more than an algorithm should
should satisfy in order to be
practically
um
practically implementable of course it
needs to be simple
we want to be able to implement it but
also test and maintain so imagine you're
like writing a tsp solver you have a
solution it's actually very difficult to
tell that the solution that you got is
what you wanted to get I mean how would
you test like if it's if it's a good tsp
solution and this becomes even harder if
the algorithm is very complicated
we want to be mindful about hidden
constants that matters a lot uh in
implementation memory usage is also an
important factor like in fact for
parallel algorithms this is the number
one limiting factor the limiting
scalability of the implementations and
it's something that yeah we don't we
don't often uh care too much about yeah
good use of cash
and I guess many others but my point is
that uh well I think I I have two
comments so first
for many of those I think that uh people
working on algorithms are the most
qualified to address I think people who
take an algorithm and want to implement
it they can deal with some of the
challenges but many of them I would say
that it's you know it's it's us people
working on a theory that that are best
qualified to address
uh and the second point is that Dynamic
algorithms have even more
requirements that they need to satisfy
in order to be to be easy to use in
practice like we want to be a dynamic
algorithm to be faster than we're
Computing from scratch and it's not
obvious in many cases especially
especially once we start uh comparing to
some smart heuristics there are other
other properties like history
Independence imagine you're so we would
like your solution to not to not depend
on the sequence of updates that came
only at the the last uh the last
um well the edges that are in this in
this current version because for example
if you if you stop your your algorithm
for example to to update implementation
you restart you often don't want the
solution to change dramatically and
history Independence allows us to to
achieve that
so I think there is a lot that a lot of
work that
um that needs to go into into making
Dynamic algorithm practical and I think
I hope that some of those May motivate
uh some future working here
and then final thought uh before before
the wrap up is I was thinking that in
the case of static algorithms
um a lot of research went into
identifying some useful properties of
the graphs we work with we know that
real world graphers bars they have
parallel degree distributions low
diameter and so on
but for update sequences I'm not really
aware of any of any assumptions that we
may be able to to exploit like we
sometimes study random or random order
sequences but I think we have very
little understanding of of what the
actual update sequences are and and we
know they matter a lot to how the
algorithms perform and practice
stories now this is really the final
slide I think okay I'm just one minute
it's over so just so to summarize uh
dynamic
page rank is is quite easy under random
updates
at the same time maintaining
multiplicative approximation in the
worst case is probably hard
we can approximate it uh we can we can
give an additive approximation in
amortized poly log time
uh but then at the same time batchware
computation is a very competitive
solution we've seen empirical results
and then some open questions are can we
extend uh solutions to pagerank to
Adaptive adversaries can we maybe
further improve battery computation with
some kind of local tweaks between direct
computations and more generally uh how
can we make Dynamic algorithms uh easier
to use in practice I guess this may be a
topic for for lots of follow-up research
that's all I have thank you
[Applause]
thanks Google happy to
yeah just one quick question
um
so the lower band that you mentioned for
the multiplicative approximations was
for two approximations what about like
larger multiplicative approximations I
think that it may actually rule out any
constant approximation as far as
so yeah I think we actually as I
mentioned I think we can we can make
some vertices like oscillate between a
constant and one over polylog page rank
a large number of times which will rule
out
foreign
goodness of life
um thanks for the talk so I have a
question related to your point on static
versus Dynamic algorithm so the static
page rank algorithm has much lower
overheads because you don't actually
need to store the random walks and you
can just do like sparse Matrix back to
multiply so I'm wondering at what point
does the static algorithm actually do
better than the batch recomputation
algorithm like how large of a batch size
um do you need in order for the static
one to actually do better and vice versa
I mean I'm guessing like for large
enough batches you probably should just
recompute it using the static algorithm
right I mean what do we do okay maybe
let me clarify when we have we have a
graph we got some number of updates and
our our battery computation approach I
think okay I'm using batch in slightly
maybe slightly different way that than
what has been used before when I get a
batch of updates I add all of those
edges to the graph and I run on the
whole graph from scratch I don't I do
not process the batch I do not even
treat the batch in any special way I run
on the whole graph entirely from scratch
I see okay
um and then you like the algorithm you
run actually stores the like the random
walks right well the algorithm that I
run up for once I up once I add the
edges to the graph I use like the the
power iteration oh I see okay yeah so
this is what hap what's happening after
every collection of updates I see okay
all right yeah so this is exactly uh why
why this battery competition step is as
you point out that's why it's it's so
fast because it's a cheap algorithm to
run
thank you for the talk I I want to go to
a meta Point uh building off your
observation which I very much agree that
we as algorithm designers are often in
the best
position to help make our algorithms
practical and it raises a question for
me how as a community we incentivize
that kind of work I think uh the sort of
the standard socks response would be
Allen X or or SCA but I don't I I think
those are really focused on uh
experiment and sort of the science of
doing experiments and I I don't see them
as perfect vehicles for incentivizing or
giving great examples of that kind of
work so you know I'd like to see the
Community start thinking about or or
those those in the community who who
really believe in
in implementations and in making
algorithms practical to figure out
um some additional vehicles for that
um Sosa is another
another step in that in that direction
but but maybe there's another kind of
step we can take as a community yep yeah
thanks for the comment I definitely
agree uh I there is also acda like a new
initiative which I think is also like on
the intersection of of theory and that's
the systems the acda no no this is not
icde but acda that's uh
I think juliani had students right who
submitted to acba right I think it's
applied and occupational discrete albums
yeah
applied competition discrete algorithms
yes yes yes yeah I've heard it I heard
they were talking yeah but but it is
like from my perspective it is difficult
to like to even find proper venues for
for work that um that has an algorithmic
component and has an applied component
and part of the reason why the result is
interesting is is that it's that it's
applicable in practice uh my feeling is
that I we when I whenever we submit a
paper I have this feeling that either
the reviewers would focus only on the
empirical part or only on the on the
theoretical part and like there are many
cases where the papers are not to be
treated holistically this paper for
context is under submission to nearest
Which honestly I don't think it's like a
canonical venue where where work like
this could go but yeah but I I do think
we may be uh
yes so and they're not they're not a lot
of uh of venues that were this works
like this naturally belonging
so I think this is a great discussion to
take um offline now and
um I I will close the the session um for
now because we're already a bit over
time and
um
thanks Cuba again thanks
[Applause]